für jeden richtigen kommen gibt es nicht
besser so ist mir schwanger aber
natürlich nur selbst gesammelte das ist
was fans schwan oder river experten
sondern auf lateinisch die
pilze
auf lateinisch konnte ein neues hobby
doch gesagt auf den seiten gibt es
nichts ist gefährlicher ist wie ein
pilzgericht dort seien schon dreimal
mehr als wir in der donau von heike
rissen worden sein man muss sich schon
gut auskennen das heißt expertise
es ist ein wunderschöner röhrling nicht
zu verwechseln mit denen der wo ganz
genau so ausschaut aber tot ist giftig
ist dort probiert
sie scannt man kann nicht vorsichtig
genug sein das sind 100 prozentig
ausgehen finger weg drum sorge doch
niemals source oder dokus stattlich war
sondern für seine kunden in wirtschaft